why isn't the best scene in dr strange
in the multiverse of madness the one you
think it is because the real best scene
plays into director sam raimi's biggest
strengths keep watching be warned that
spoilers are ahead it's been six years
since benedict cumberbatch first donned
the cloak of levitation as the master of
the mystic arts and director scott
derrickson's doctor strange since then
he's helped save the world from thanos
in avengers infinity war and end game
before cleaning up peter parker's
multiversal mess in spider-man and no
way home
thank you steven but the sorcerer has
finally returned for his own sequel dr
strange in the multiverse of madness in
which he explores different universes
while trying to help america chavez
escape a deadly threat it's impressive
how much director sam raimi's multiverse
of madness manages to pull off in its
two hours and seven minutes considering
it has so many key players and ideas to
establish not only does it boldly make
former avengers scarlet witch the main
villain the one seeking charvez's power
for herself but it dives head first into
the marvel multiverse exploring other
realities that exist in parallel to the
character's own earth-616 unsurprisingly
this comes with some incredibly
crowd-pleasing moments and cameos that
will surely surprise marvel fans of all
ages even if the marketing revealed
professor x and captain carter before
the film even arrived in theaters even
so the scenes in dr strange in the
multiverse of madness that offer up all
that fan service aren't the best in the
movie with sam raimi and the director's
share this time around horror fans are
really in for a treat not only does he
know how to handle superheroes and
heartfelt storytelling thanks to his
work on the spider-man trilogy in the
early 2000s he's also a master at
creating uniquely terrifying scenarios
he's perhaps best known for directing
the evil dead films and he brings some
of his signature camera moves to the
doctor strange sequel one of the key
concepts the movie introduces is the
idea of dreamwalking where a powerful
sorcerer or witch can use the darkhold
to take hold off and control their
alternate selves in another universe
when strange and chavez escaped to the
illuminati's home base of earth 838
scarlett witch from the 616 universe
used his stream walking to control the
wonder maximoff in that universe the
results are chilling the sequence shows
a happier wonder who lives with her two
sons billy and tommy in a quiet suburban
area not unlike west view from one
division it isn't long before sucker mum
wonder realizes she's been hunted by a
supernatural force that follows her
through the house there are glimpses of
the scarlet witch's eyes and reflective
surfaces as well as free-flowing pov
camera shots that swoop through the
house before the villain takes over her
alternate self entirely it doesn't seem
fair it's psychedelic trippy and
downright creepy fans of raymie's work
will love it the trailers for dr strange
and the multiverse of madness heavily
focused on the sequence where the
titular hero meets the illuminati in an
alternate universe likely because of its
fan-pleasing nature yes meeting john
krasinski's mr fantastic is well
fantastic even the return of anson
mounts black bolts is a sight to behold
but it doesn't exactly serve the story
other than as a cautionary tale for
strange the cameos are exciting but they
do feel like an easy bit of fan service
with only marginal story value the
creepy scene in the maximoff house on
the other hand proves that when the mcu
leans into a specific genre it really
excels like it did in phase one iron man
is an action thriller thor is a fantasy
adventure and captain america the first
avenger is a war movie since then the
mcu has mainly stuck to the general
superhero genre with the occasional
diversion into spy thrillers with the
winter soldier or kung fu films with
shanghai doctor strange going full
horror is raymie doing what he does best
you may remember similar flourishes in
his spiderman movies for characters like
steven strange and scarlet witch this
works perfectly even narratively wonder
possessing the body of her alternate
self shows that she's willing to do
whatever it takes to be with her
children because she's struggling to
cope after suffering so much less it was
one of those rare moments in a marvel
movie where fans really have no idea how
it's going to play out and seeing
scarlet witch go full big bad is
viciously
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you